si neymar avant de retrouver dans un
instant kirsten dunst la fiancée de
spiderman
à quoi ressemble le troisième opus de la
série qui sort sur les écrans mercredi
prochain un super héros plus sombre des
effets spéciaux plus étonnant encore une
production abouti au succès garanti
pascal deschamps difficile de s'adresser
en moins de deux minutes à la fois aux
fans de la série à ceux qui n'y
connaissent rien comme à ceux qui
ricanent face aux aventures post pubères
du type aux colombes le disons que dans
le genre film de super héros spider man
a du style mélange réussi d'efficacité
d'autodérision et de profondeur
cette fois ce fireman va découvrir qu'il
n'est pas juste quelqu'un devient la
vengeance est comme un poison
elle peut s'emparer de nous
nous transformer en hausse ce costume
d'où vient-il que j'aime chez peter hill
et qu'il est en train de découvrir ce
qu'est l'être humain il est vraiment
mais c'est un voyage que nous faisons
tous et auquel on peut aussi dans le
crochet votre connaissance s'identifier
jusqu'à un certain point tout de même
car en plus de la jalousie de sa copine
[__] va se frotter à deux super
méchant l'homme sable et surtout venom
l'occasion d'une scène de métamorphose
comment dire
v no mé nal
que c'est un gros film fait spéciaux
mais dans ce cadre une merde je crois
qu'on a réussi à exprimer pas mal
d'émotion pour résumer ce troisième opus
devrait ravir les fans séduire les
novices quant à ceux qui ricanent tant
pis pour eux